Jean-François Longeot cher Vincent mes
chers collègues merci de d'être venu
nombreuses matin pour nous écouter bon
je vais laisser longuement la parole sur
les 15 minutes qui nous ont répartis à
Vincent Delahaye qui est à l'origine de
d'une résolution présentée par les
membres du groupe centriste et comme
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
Président la Commission d'enquête a été
constituée le 29 janvier 2020 alors pour
vous rappeler vous donner une note
d'ambiance parce que ce rapport il est
conséquent et il est il a nous avons
procédé à une vingtaine d'auditions avec
les principaux acteurs nous avons
visionné la RT nous avons auditionné les
ministres en place au moment de la
privatisation
au moment de en 2015 2016-2017 pour le
plan d'investissement autoroutier
important qui a eu lieu
après la loi Macron et nous avons
d'ailleurs auditionné Alexis Kohler
nous avons auditionné 20 une vingtaine
et notre rapporteur nous c'était en
plein covid notre rapporteur a eu une
trentaine de d'auditions techniques et
véritablement ce rapport s'appuie sur
une démarche je veux dire même
scientifique mathématiques
je crois que Vincent il faut il faut le
dire puisque nous avons auditionné aussi
les
usagers et nous avons rendu notre
rapport la conclusion du rapport le 6
mai le au mois de septembre pardon le 16
septembre
2020 et nous avons débattu en séance
publique
en séance publique le 6 mai 2021 donc
nous ignorions un peu l'histoire du
rapport de l'IGF
et cette moi je vous remercie monsieur
le Président et votre commission d'avoir
remis cette
ce sujet à l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée parce que longtemps et à
chaque condition notre rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête a toujours appelé
et les
usagers notamment des nous espérons que
ce n'est pas un rapport pour rien un
nouveau rapport pour rien non ce n'était
pas un rapport pour rien le rapporteur
l'a rappelé à multiples reprises c'est
un rapport de commission d'enquête donc
nous avons eu des moyens pour travailler
important plus important que un simple
rapport commission d'enquête il y a une
obligation de présence du ministre de
Villepin par exemple si vous voulez
nonoyale qui nous ont expliqué et
parfois de manière un peu surprenante
les décisions qui pouvaient être de
cette importance pouvant être prise mais
ça c'est un petit compte bancaire vous
avez un monsieur le Président rappeler
les recommandations qui sont issues de
ce rapport ce n'est pas un rapport pour
rien bon il est clair
au mois de février c'est l'augmentation
des tarifs et cette année dans pleine
inflation une augmentation
jugée quand même très importantes
par rapport aux difficultés rencontrées
par nos concitoyens ça a mis le sujet
sur le en débat le ministre s'est
exprimé suite à une fuite dans la presse
alors on est prudent parce que Vincent
delaix il a une particularité c'est
qu'il ne l'a jamais rien
nous avons rencontré le ministre Beaune
il n'y a pas très longtemps il y a
quelques semaines pour lui demander un
sujet qui était très important que vous
avez de l'objet d'un rapport c'était une
table ronde sur les autoroutes se mettre
enfin autour de la table pour avoir une
discussion et mettre tous les sujets
parce que
c'est toujours très conflictuel c'est ce
regard que nous portons sur les
concessions autoroutières donc il était
dans l'idée d'avoir cette ces assises
alors c'est annoncé par paiement bonne
attendons pour voir les débats enfin le
débat ouvert par le ministre des
Finances je j'espère que ce n'est pas un
contre-feu à une espèce de une annonce
faite bon il envoie
la question au Conseil d'État peut-on
raccourcir dans notre rapport en
indiquait quand même que et vous verrez
les concessionnaires puisque vous avez
les auditionné on va dire qu'ils sont
des positifs d'un contrat
et globalement le contrat il est plutôt
béton de leur côté avec des juristes de
très haut niveau
et nous avons pu parfois dire que ces
contrats ils étaient déséquilibrés et
largement en faveur des concessionnaires
et que notre travail et nos conclusions
et ensuite Vincent vous va vous parler
de manière plus précise c'était de
rééquilibrer il y a pas un rejet du
modèle concessif même si
certains de nos collègues ont pu déposer
des des projets de
je te vois donc
il y a des alternatives possibles et il
faut d'ailleurs réfléchir à ou devenir
des concessions et c'est d'ailleurs un
axe important dans les recommandations
du rapport c'est préparé la fin des
concessions alors on a encore peut-être
un petit peu de temps sauf s'il y a un
raccourcissement mais c'est un
feuilleton à suivre attendant le rendu
du Conseil du Conseil d'État sur la
proposition faite par le Ministre
de l'économie mais moi je suis un peu
circonspect sur cette annonce elle tombe
au moment d'une crise sociale majeure
dans notre pays et est-ce que c'est pour
détourner l'attention peut-être c'est
une question que je me pose où
irons-nous avec cette ce sujet mais
merci en tous les cas chers président
d'avoir avec votre commission remis ce
sujet dans le débat de notre assemblée
merci pour ces propos liminaires
merci monsieur le Président cher
Jean-François bonjour à tous
effectivement Éric vient de le dire la
commission d'enquête a permis quand même
de mettre à plat un petit peu tout ce
qui était autour des concessions
historiques les concessions qui font
quand même 9000 km sur 12000 km
d'autoroute et qui sont qui sont
occupés par trois groupes principaux
Vinci Eiffage et à berthys
on a créé cette commission d'enquête et
on est j'étais à l'origine un peu la
création de cette commission d'enquête
pour que on puisse faire un point
complet sur le dossier et surtout que on
puisse aider le gouvernement et l'État à
rééquilibrer un peu le rapport de force
avec les sociétés concessionnaires parce
qu'on a un peu trop la pression que le
rapport de force il est que dans un sens
et quand on est conséquent on doit aussi
avoir un poids et à mon avis ce poids
était insuffisant en tout cas on l'a
marqué alors
on a on a bien sûr fait beaucoup de
propositions mais je dirais qu'il y en
avait trois principales la première
c'était surtout de ne pas prolonger les
contrats existants d'arrêter le système
de travaux contre prorogation ce qui
s'est passé en 2015 en 24 milliards de
travaux et 3 ans de progression en fait
les sociétés d'autoroute ils gagnent
largement donc la collectivité il perd
et
elle y perd parce que les contrats
historiques en fait il y a un vice à la
base il y a péché originel c'est que on
n'a pas modifié les contrats au moment
de la privatisation ça a commencé avec
Lionel Jospin en 2002 avec 20% de des
autos du sud de la France et puis de
Villepin avec tout le reste et à ce
moment-là c'est vrai qu'il aurait fallu
modifier ses contrats et on fait pas des
contrats de longue durée sans clause de
revoyure il y a aucune clause de
revoyure dans ces contrats moi j'aurais
presque tendance à dire que c'est des
contrats Léonard parce que on peut pas
avoir des contrats d'une vingtaine
d'années sont surtout de revoyure donc
c'est ça le vice à l'origine et c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression
qu'il faut absolument pas toucher à ses
contrats et que dès qu'on touche une
virgule on touche à l'équilibre des
contrats pour les sociétés d'autoroutes
vous écouterez les les concessionnaires
et vous leur demanderez comment ils
définissent l'équilibre économique et
financier les contrats parce que c'est
notre deuxième point notre premier point
c'est pas de progression et ça je pense
que
l'action du Sénat a permis d'arrêter ces
histoires parce qu'il y en avait dans
les tiroirs du ministère il y avait
encore des projets de progression contre
des travaux donc je pense que ça c'est
vraiment le premier point il faut
arrêter à minima se dire que les dates
de 2031 à 2036 c'est vraiment des dates
butoir on viendra peut-être tout à
l'heure un petit peu sur la réduction
éventuelle de ces dates mais en tout cas
c'est des dates plutôt deuxième point
c'est l'équilibre économique et
financier des contrats dans un contrat
de concession c'est le point central
c'est le point central c'est le noeud et
il est toujours évoqué mais en fait il
est jamais défini cet équilibre il a
jamais été défini donc nous dans nos
conclusions on souhaitait effectivement
qui est une table ronde avec les
concessionnaires avec l'État avec la RT
avec tout le monde que tout le monde
vienne autour de la table pour dire
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette équilibre
économique et financier de ces contrats
alors nous on l'a on a essayé de le
définir au niveau de la Commission on
s'est dit c'est équilibre économique est
financier des contrats c'est la
rentabilité attendue par les
actionnaires donc les actionnaires quand
ils ont investi en 2006 et en 2002
depuis 2006 ils se sont fixés des
objectifs de rentabilité c'était 8% à
peu près et on s'est dit qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette rentabilité actionnaire
donc on l'a défini on a publié des
chiffres on a pris le risque de publier
des chiffres parce que les sociétés
d'autoroute elle elle nous donnait des
chiffres mais toujours couverts par le
secret des affaires donc vous pourrez
leur poser des questions sur ce secret
des affaires aussi parce que des
contrats qui vont jusqu'en 2036 avec le
à secret des affaires moi ça me fait un
peu rigoler mais en tout cas tout ce qui
nous ont donné on n'a jamais pu le
publier donc on a publié nos propres
prévisions qui sont pas très loin des
leurs
et qui sont pas les leurs et on a publié
nos prévisions et aujourd'hui
2021-2022 ont largement confirmé nos
prévisions et donc à partir de ces
prévisions on a pu calculer la
rentabilité actionnaire soit durée du
contrat parce que les sociétés
d'autoroute vont vous dire la
rentabilité on la verra à la fin des
contrats donc pour l'instant rien à dire
rien à rien à discuter on verra bien ce
qui se passera à la fin c'est à la fin
qu'on comptera les points mais à la fin
ça sera trop tard donc aujourd'hui on
considère qu'effectivement Vinci
notamment à atteint aura atteint les 8%
fin 2023 pour Eiffage c'est fin 2024
Eiffage ils ont plutôt des contrats qui
se terminent en 2034 donc ils auront une
dizaine d'années Vinci 2023 ça va
jusqu'en 2036 vous voyez il y a quand
même 13 ans pour avertisse aberti c'est
les le nord et la Normandie eux ils ont
les contrats les plus courts qui se
termine en 2031 et on considère que leur
rentabilité sera atteinte à peu près en
2031 moi j'aurais tendance à dire à
faire deux groupes Abertis où on a à la
limite pas grand chose à qui ne doit pas
dire que il faut pas regarder ce qu'il
faut et mais on a Vinci Eiffage de
l'autre côté sur lesquels il faut quand
même réagir donc cet équilibre
économique et financier c'est
fondamental le rapport de l'IGF qui est
sorti l'inspection générale des finances
qui était normalement secret qui a fini
par sortir en fait à confirmé la méthode
la méthodologie que nous avions
appliquée au niveau de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat pour établir la
rentabilité actionnaire ils ont dit
qu'il y avait quelques petites erreurs
méthodologiques je conteste cette cet
aspect là dont je vais écrire Bruno Le
Maire pour lui contester les
surmatologie puisque le rapport de IGF a
repris en fait les réponses de nourris
le président de défage et qui ne
concernait pas en fait la méthodologie
elle-même mais quelques informations
qu'on n'avait pas et bon donc on va
corriger cela mais en tout cas pour moi
c'est validé et c'est quand même un gros
élément de alors sur ce sujet
méfiez-vous l'IGF dit ils vont avoir
atteint 12% à la fin
nous on disait 11 30 on est à peu près
dans les mêmes eaux et
la RT si vous regardez l'Autorité de
régulation des transports eux ils vous
disent ah on a une rentabilité qui est à
peu près à 7,6 donc en fait les sociétés
d'autoroute se servent beaucoup de la RT
en disant regardez la RT il considère
pas qu'il y a une surentabilité en
réalité la RT calcul d'une rentabilité
projet
alors on sait même pas comment il a
calcule parce que si vous regardez bien
leur rapport on n'a pas le détail du
calcul puisque le projet en fait on sait
pas le reconstituer on sait pas
reconstituer le coût du projet donc je
pense qu'ils l'ont fait de façon
théorique mais il nous le donne pas il
nous donne pas le résultat on sait pas
on sait pas à combien il siffle le
projet ils disent voilà le projet
l'infrastructure elle a coûté tant et on
définit la rentabilité par rapport à
cela nous c'est pas notre optique notre
optique c'est de dire les sociétés qui
ont repris ces contrats ont donné de
l'argent à l'origine c'est des
actionnaires qui ont donné de l'argent
et qu'est-ce que ça leur a rapporté que
voilà c'est c'est ça et ça c'est assez
facile à recalculer donc on n'a pas le
même calcul de rentabilité entre la RT
nous le Sénat et l'IGF qui a validé la
démarche du Sénat donc ça il faut que
vous l'ayez bien en tête parce que c'est
c'est un élément très important donc
donc pour nous se mettre autour de la
table et se dire on va effectivement
discuter
discuter de cet équilibre économique et
financier pourquoi c'est important parce
que quand vous avez des contrats de
concession vous avez été élu local on a
pas mal de contrats de concessions les
sociétés concessionnaires peuvent
remettre en cause les contrats si elle
considère que l'équilibre financier
n'est pas celui qui les avait prévu à
l'origine moi ça m'est déjà arrivé en
tant que mère et d'avoir des discussions
obligatoires avec les sociétés
concessionnaires qui disaient on avait
prévu de gagner de l'argent en fait on
gagne pas pour telle raison il faut
revoir le contrat et elles ont le droit
de dénoncer le contrat donc moi je vois
pas parallélisme des formes pourquoi
aujourd'hui on ne pourrait pas dénoncer
des contrats à partir du moment on
considère que l'équilibre économique et
financier est atteint
sur l'ensemble du contrat quand je dis
2023 pour Vinci ça veut dire que les 8%
ils seront atteints même si Vinci fait 0
jusqu'à la fin des contrats entre entre
2024 et 2036 s'ils font un résultat à 0
ce qui font absolument pas mais s'il
faisait ça on serait on serait quand
même à l'équilibre donc voilà donc moi
je considère que l'étape mettre la
pression et l'objet de notre action
aujourd'hui c'est d'essayer de mettre de
la pression sur l'état et sur le
gouvernement de façon à ce que on
rééquilibre le rapport de force avec les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute et
ensuite la troisième recommandation
c'était de préparer l'avenir et votre
commission qui se saisit du sujet à mon
avis est bien dans la ligne de ce que ce
qu'on a fait c'est à dire que il faut
dès maintenant préparer l'avenir même si
les contrats allaient à leur terme
moi ce que je ne souhaite pas donc la
saisine du Conseil d'État par Bruno Le
Maire j'espère qu'on en aura le détail
moi je vais en tout cas je vais en
demander le détail et je voudrais avoir
la réponse du Conseil d'État si le
gouvernement joue la transparence on
devrait obtenir quand même c'est à la
fois les questions et les et la réponse
du Conseil d'État parce que je voudrais
bien m'assurer que ça correspond bien au
contrat actuel et pas au contrats futur
que réduire la durée des contrats futurs
je pense que tout le monde en est
d'accord après on est d'accord ou pas
sur le système de concession pour ma
part moi je pense que c'est un bon
système à partir du moment on a des bons
contrats et un bon suivi et là on n'a
pas un bon contrat et pendant quelques
pendant un certain nombre d'années on
n'a pas eu un bon suivi donc c'est vrai
que c'est pas c'est pas mon système
sinon on a des sociétés compétentes qui
travaillent bien voilà qui qui font bien
leur boulot et donc la préparation de
l'avenir c'est important à la fois pour
réfléchir ce qu'on fait
est-ce qu'on continue la concession sur
quelle durée avec quel type de contrat
on a des contrats aujourd'hui qui sont
bien mieux ficelés qu'avant est-ce qu'on
fait une société des autoroutes de
France Olivier Jacquin on a discuté
c'est vrai que c'est peut-être un sujet
intéressant
même si on a système concession c'est
d'avoir une société qui permette de
récupérer de l'argent et de le flécher
sur les travaux sur les routes et sur
les infrastructures de transport parce
que sinon on a du mal à fléchir
l'affectation des ressources à des
dépenses donc peut-être que c'est c'est
un bon sujet et en tous les cas il faut
absolument veiller à ce que on est des
infrastructures d'autoroutes qui
reviennent en bon état c'est-à-dire dans
les contrats il est prévu que le
concessionnaire remette en bon état et
dans ce qu'on a vu nous on a plutôt vu
une baisse des investissements sur les
dernières années de contrat ce qui est
assez classique et j'ai l'impression que
ça avait un peu échappé à la DGTM et à
la RT mais en tout cas il faut bien
regarder que les concessions les
concessionnaires vont continuer à
investir autant chaque année jusqu'à la
fin des
parce que sinon on aura des autoroutes
qui reviendront en mauvais état donc
voilà je vais peut-être dépassé les 15
minutes je sais pas trop mais j'ai
essayé de vous résumer à la fois par
rapport à la non progression des
contrats à l'équilibre économique et
financier contrats et à la préparation
de l'avenir qu'il faut travailler dès
maintenant quel que soit les décisions
qui sont prises même si on a une
réduction des encore plus si on a une
réduction de la durée des contrats et il
faut pas craindre les contentieux parce
que les sociétés d'autoroute elle part
toujours en contentieux vous savez là
elles sont en contentieux avec l'État
aujourd'hui pour une indexation des
taxes d'aménagement on a décidé en 2020
dans la loi de finances l'indexer les
taxes d'aménagement ils disent ah ça va
nous coûter un milliard d'ici la fin des
contrats d'ici 2036 tout cumulés la
baisse de l'IS de 33 à 25% leur apporte
jusqu'à la fin des contrats 7 milliards
d'euros donc voyez il y a 1 milliard un
milliard il faut un contentieux et les 7
milliards ils empochent tranquillement
de l'autre côté donc il y a un moment
donné où c'est pas possible alors ils
ont beaucoup de moyens ils ont beaucoup
de juristes ils ont moyen de payer
beaucoup de juristes avec public
d'ailleurs puisque c'est l'argent de
nous tous de tous les utilisateurs à un
moment donné il faut aussi que l'État et
la puissance publique puisse leur
montrer que on n'a pas peur et que on
n'a pas peur d'un éventuel contentieux
ben voilà si si un contentieux il y a
contentieux mais d'un autre côté il faut
vraiment que le rapport de force
s'inverse voilà ce que je voulais dire
en introduction monsieur le Président en
espérant avoir été le plus synthétique
possible merci merci donc on va donner
la parole à nos à nos collègues pour le
couple républicains suite d'un appareil
à Laurence Muller Rhône
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues alors vous nous avez bien
expliqué résumé la problématique donc je
passerai directement aux questions pour
ne pas perdre de temps donc selon vous
comment l'État doit-il aujourd'hui
renégocier ces contrats quelle est la
marge de manœuvre du gouvernement et que
peut-il obtenir pour rééquilibrer les
bénéfices et partager les gains
d'exploitation sans renation
renégociation des contrats quel serait
le montant des pertes pour l'État
à plus long terme est-il envisageable de
réduire au moins de moitié la durée des
concessions et de prévoir des clauses de
modération tarifaire en fonction des
bénéfices et des seuils de rentabilité
quelles sont les pistes envisageables
pour exploiter la rentabilité de ces
sociétés au bénéfice des usagers par
exemple inclure dans les contrats une
réduction significative du prix des
abonnements pour les trajets quotidiens
domicile travail
depuis la publication du rapport de la
commission d'enquête du Sénat avez-vous
constaté une évolution et une ouverture
du gouvernement qui se rapprocherait du
constat et des recommandations que vous
avez formulées mais d'après ce que vous
avez dit pas vraiment en d'autres termes
pensez-vous qu'il existe aujourd'hui une
volonté politique de s'attaquer à ses
contrats une volonté qui va falloir
encourager d'après ce que nous avons
compris aussi alors j'ai également
quelques questions de la part de notre
collègue Philippe Tabarro est-ce que je
les voulais envoie dans la foulée oui
allons-y allons-y alors de la part de
Philippe que pensez-vous des rapports de
l'IGF et de la RT vous nous en avez
parlé en comparaison avec vos propres
conclusions qui avaient été jugé trop à
charge en 2020 feriez-vous les mêmes
constats aujourd'hui et enfin quel
montant les concessionnaires
pourraient-ils dégager pour les affecter
aux rails
voilà messieurs merci
merci on va regrouper toutes les
questions et puis tu crois qu'on répond
pas d'abord je pense que c'est
non parce que après bon je dis pas qu'on
va les oublier parce que ces
questions-là on se les pose aussi donc
très largement donc on les a en tête
mais je pense que pour la clarté du
débat c'est peut-être pas mal de
répondre immédiatement
alors
l'assurantabilité ce qu'on a considéré
d'abord
honnêtement nos conclusions on les
maintiendrait aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
raison de ne pas maintenir ce que le
travail qu'on a fait il y a rien qui qui
a évolué ce qui évolue quand même un
petit peu c'est quand même la prise en
compte et la prise de conscience du
gouvernement Bruno Le Maire l'a dit à
l'Assemblée nationale elle a été
auditionnée la semaine dernière il a dit
qu'il reconnaissait quand même qu'il y
avait une sur rentabilité ce qui est ce
qui était pas le cas avant quand on
l'avait auditionné on avait auditionné
comme Elisabeth borne ici mais dans
cette salle même et il avait pas reconnu
donc je dirais qu'il y a une évolution
il y a une prise en compte le fait qu'il
saisisse le Conseil d'État pour dire on
pourrait peut-être réduire la durée des
contrats c'est aussi un élément à
prendre en compte donc on sent qu'il y a
une prise de conscience et que cette
prise de conscience elle vient
effectivement du travail qui a été
réalisé à la fois du nôtre mais aussi de
l'aspect médiatique parce que c'est vrai
que le fait que les médias sont saisis
c'est on parle beaucoup et moi je suis
assez sollicité sur sur ce plan là
ça ça continue et ça procède de la
pression d'ensemble pour que les choses
évoluent parce que la volonté bien sûr
des sociétés d'autoroutes c'est que rien
évolue d'ici la fin des contrats et même
que ils puissent pourrez leur contrat
actuel donc c'est c'est leur discours
c'est dire voilà il y a encore beaucoup
d'investissements à faire on a 60
milliards soi-disant 60 milliards pour
verdir les autoroutes on sait pas très
bien ce qu'il y a dans les 60 milliards
mais vous voyez 60 milliards c'est
énorme vous vous rendez compte et nous
ce qu'on chiffre comme sur rentabilité
ce qu'on a chiffré qu'on continue
d'ailleurs de de chiffrer c'est à peu
près entre 30 et 35 milliards à peu près
après après
l'atteinte des des 8% dont j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure donc à partir de 2023
après fin 2023 pour Vinci et fin 2024
pour Eiffage on peut considérer qu'il y
a 30 35 milliards et c'est pour ça qu'on
avait titré notre notre rapport sur le
fait qu'il y avait des on avait pas des
super profits mais il y avait une
rentabilité à partager entre les
concessionnaires l'État et les usagers
en tout cas qu'il y avait une discussion
à avoir et lors de grandeur c'est à peu
près ça c'est 30-35 milliards donc ça ça
reste ça reste aujourd'hui
en cours de discussion alors après
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que peut faire
l'état moi je pense que l'État à un
moment donné doit montrer sa volonté et
le fait que les concessionnaires sont
pas tout puissants parce que ils ont eu
un moment donné des contrats que ces
contrats ils ont une vie ils ont on peut
les critiquer on peut les critiquer sur
le fond
alors c'est vrai que à l'époque on avait
demandé ici
j'avais demandé à Dominique de Villepin
pourquoi ils avaient pas modifié les
contrats alors lui il m'avait dit ah ben
Lionel Jospin avait commencé en 2002 à
ouvrir le capital d'autoroute du sud de
la France au privé et donc à partir du
moment où les le capital était ouvert au
privé on pouvait plus modifier
je trouve que c'est un peu court comme
réponse parce que
en réalité comme on relancer un appel
d'offres sur le reste sur la mise sur le
marché du reste on pouvait très bien
dire bah écoutez cet appel d'offre il
est avec des contrats modifiés et puis
on a je pense que c'est à l'époque on a
voulu aller assez vite comme souvent
d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup de décisions
qui se prennent très rapidement et du
coup on prend pas le temps de faire tout
à fond et à l'époque on avait on n'a pas
pris le temps de le faire à fond donc
après en 2015 quand il y a eu le
protocole d'accord qui a été signé par
Emmanuel Macron et Ségolène Royal
Ségolène Royal qui nous a dit qu'elle
n'avait pas
elle n'avait pas connaissance du contenu
du protocole avant de le lire dans la
presse en fait elle a signé sans savoir
ce qu'elle signait donc monsieur j'ai
trouvé ça quand même assez assez
aberrant mais dans ce protocole d'accord
il y avait quelques petites
modifications du contrat mais à la marge
et notamment par rapport à la
rentabilité la rentabilité si vous
regardez la clause qui est prévue dans
le le code de 2015 sur le entre
guillemets les excès de rentabilité
c'est des c'est des cibles
inatteignables c'est à dire que elles
seront jamais atteintes quel que soit
l'évolution du trafic quasiment c'est
pas possible donc à un moment donné il
faut il faut quand même sérieux discuter
sérieusement ne pas s'en laisser compter
parce que les sociétés concessionnaires
ont tendance effectivement à faire
rapidement du chantage et dire vous
inquiétez pas on va on va aller devant
la justice et vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir bon c'est vrai qu'en
2015 il y avait eu la décision
unilatérale aussi de Ségolène Royal de
gelée et tarifs de 2015
décisions qui en fait mettait l'état un
petit peu en position de faiblesse dans
la négociation c'était pas simple parce
que là là en l'occurrence elle avait
pris vraiment une décision qui était
absolument pas conforme au contrat et
sans aucune concertation sans rien donc
c'est vrai que alors en plus ça a été
rattrapé c'est avec le rattrapage de
2015 ça s'est établi jusqu'en 2023 c'est
à dire que cette année on paye encore le
rattrapage de 2015 c'est la dernière on
va payer 2015 et que tout le rattrapage
a été plus important que ce qu'aurait
subisse automobile uniquement en 2015
donc il faut aussi avoir ça en tête
c'est la négociation elle s'est faite
rapidement en début 2015 encore une fois
trois rapidement c'est souvent trop
rapide c'est pour ça que anticiper comme
vous le faites et comme on a essayé de
le faire au niveau de la commission
d'enquête c'est important parce que
c'est important de d'anticiper l'avenir
d'avoir bien conscience de l'ensemble du
sujet et de pouvoir anticiper cela il
s'agit pas pour moi en tout cas
personnellement d'éliminer les sociétés
des sociétés compétentes des sociétés
privées et je ne dis pas qu'elles
doivent pas gagner d'argent parce que
moi je considère qu'une société privée
doit gagner de l'argent c'est normal
sinon il y a plus personne qui va
travailler mais faut que ça soit
raisonnable faut que ça soit raisonnable
et des clauses d'encadrement de la
rentabilité si on disait on discute on a
une clause de revoyure tous les trois
ans par exemple on fait des contrats de
12 ou 15 ans
je dis ça comme ça mais j'ai même pas
réfléchi à durer mais qu'on se dise tous
les trois ans on se remet autour de la
table et si la rentabilité a varié de
plus ou moins 5% mais on regarde les
conséquences et la discussion qu'on peut
avoir c'est des choses qui peuvent tout
à fait s'imaginer c'est pas aberrant et
puis voilà et il gagne correctement leur
vie à 8 % honnêtement c'est c'est bien
gagner sa vie on aimerait tous avoir des
placements à 8% bon
voilà et après la durée des contrats
dépendra effectivement des
investissements qu'on leur demandera
aussi parce que forcément si si on
considère qu'il y a beaucoup
d'investissements à faire les contrats
sont plus longs s'il y en a beaucoup
moins ils sont plus courts donc voilà je
sais pas si j'ai répondu un peu à toutes
vos questions et j'aurais peut-être
oublié de
le train pour le financement de d'autres
infrastructures alors
alors ce qu'on peut dégager la marge la
marge d'ici 20306 c'est 30-35 milliards
c'est ce que je disais après
ça c'est la marge globale dans laquelle
il faut regarder la répartition et la
façon d'affecter la façon d'affecter cet
argent comment il peut remonter et
comment on peut l'affecter au
financement d'autres d'autres
infrastructures de transport ça moi j'ai
pas forcément la réponse là c'est vrai
que c'est une question c'est une
question que je pense que votre
commission doit examinée dans le cadre
de ces travaux essayer de réfléchir à la
façon dont ça peut se faire est-ce que
c'est la création du société spécifique
est-ce que c'est enfin je me méfie
toujours la création de structure
supplémentaires je l'ai dit à Olivier je
suis toujours un peu parce que les
structures supplémentaires c'est souvent
des coûts supplémentaires donc il faut
il faut toujours un peu se méfier de ça
ceci étant s'il y a une vraie
justification et un vrai intérêt pour
pour l'État et pour la collectivité
publique pourquoi pas
maintenant maintenant voilà la
contribution la contribution volontaire
qu'on a qu'on a inscrite moi je je
comprends même pas qu'on est inscrit ça
comme contribution volontaire j'aurais
dit c'est une contribution c'est tout il
y a pas de volontariat vous avez de
l'argent vous ne contribuez et puis
c'est tout allez dire c'est volontaire
là maintenant si juridiquement il se
base sur le truc c'est volontaire ah bah
nous si on veut plus on veut plus bah
attendez ça marche pas comme ça
au niveau
mais vas-y tempête un petit peu sur les
relations qu'on peut avoir avec les
concessionnaires et les renégociations
alors c'est pas simple
mais sur le contrôle des concessions il
y a eu un avant 2015 et un après 2015 la
création de la RT est un point très
positif et finalement je pense que les
concessionnaires à l'époque étaient
assez hostile à la création de cette
autorité et pourtant ils l'ont accepté
et sur le contrôle effectivement des
concessions on voit un progrès donc il y
a des évolutions possibles faut pas
comme le dit Vincent faut pas être
résigné et se dire on peut rééquilibrer
le rapport de force entre les
concessionnaires et sans sans jeter le
propre sur le sur les grandes sociétés
autoroutières c'est pas le c'est pas le
sujet parce que nous avons quand même on
constate que nous avons des autoroutes à
un niveau très acceptable enfin de bonne
qualité ils ont fait comme dit le
rapport ils font leur travail mais quand
même au détriment de la du pouvoir des
pouvoirs publics c'est clairement avec
une rentabilité qui n'est pas notre sens
acceptable
merci on va prendre toutes les questions
là parce que sinon on n'arrivera pas on
arrivera pas dans le temps
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain Hervé gilet
merci président ce président cher
collègue sur le rapporteur
j'ai essayé de d'approfondir peut-être
certains sujets puisqu'effectivement il
y a déjà des niveaux de réponse qu'on
peut et t'apporter alors bien évidemment
votre de vos travaux ont été
particulièrement précieux puisque les
questions sont encore particulièrement
fortes notamment sur le niveau de
rentabilité et donc sur les bénéfices
aujourd'hui qui apparaissent et
notamment vous avez cité le rapport de
l'IGF qui met qui met en perspective
aussi à un certain nombre de
préconisations genre l'occasion
peut-être aussi d'y revenir mais vous en
avez forcément connaissance je voudrais
peut-être me situer plus dans l'axe
commission aménagement du territoire et
du développement durable alors d'une
part il y a bien sûr préparer la fin des
concessions mais encore faut-il que le
contrôle des travaux nécessaires pour
que le réseau soit bien en état d'issue
à la fin que ces travaux soient
effectivement bien en et bien négocier
quel est le pouvoir aujourd'hui de
vérification de cette situation qui est
quand même un élément qui est quand même
particulièrement important pour la fin
des concessions ce qui m'intéresserait
aussi c'est on parle de de ses moyens
financiers qui pourraient être alloués
mais n'y a-t-il pas aujourd'hui une
réelle opportunité aussi d'engager les
concessionnaires dans des
investissements plus lisibles plus
massifs dans l'immobilités durables on
voit qu'aujourd'hui il y a quand même
des niveaux qui sont pas suffisamment
atteints sur le déploiement des bornes
électriques bien sûr mais on voit que on
peut utiliser aussi les délaissés
autoroutiers et la loi accélération des
énergies renouvelables à cibler à un
moment donné justement et à interroger
la capacité aussi des concessionnaires
autoroutiers à promouvoir un certain
nombre de projets j'aimerais avoir votre
avis par rapport à ça vous situiez à un
moment donné vous remettiez en
perspective les travaux les propositions
de notre collègue Olivier Jacquin soit
un syndicat effectivement national en
disant mais oui mais ça va être encore
une nouvelle structure sauf que la fuite
à l'heure actuelle n'est absolument pas
outillée pour jouer le rôle d'un
véritable syndicat au niveau national si
vous me permettez l'expression c'est une
boîte à lettres ni plus ni moins donc ce
n'est absolument pas une structure
qu'elle est compétences suffisante pour
avoir une vision prospective et de mise
en œuvre d'un certain nombre de projets
au niveau national et se comporter comme
un syndicat donc soit transformer la
fibre ce qui pourrait être une chose
mais à ce moment-là on crée une nouvelle
structure donc là il y a quand même une
question de fond qui est posée sur ce
sujet là et si on parle un peu plus
d'aménagement du territoire toujours en
lien avec Olivier Jacquin on peut aussi
s'interroger sur une régionalisation car
après tout aujourd'hui un certain nombre
de syndicats régionaux par exemple je
parle de la nouvelle Aquitaine prenons
cet exemple n'ont pas forcément les
moyens nécessaires de pouvoir
accompagner aussi une politique de
projet à l'échelle régionale et de
l'accompagner en subsidiarité avec
l'ensemble des partis prenantes sur le
plan régional ne pourrait-on pas à ce
moment-là
une part affectée également au niveau
régional ce qui permettrait d'avoir et
de développer une vision d'ensemble sur
des projets qui nécessitent des
complémentarités qui nécessitent des
schémas d'organisation et de
planification donc j'aimerais bien avoir
votre vision à ce niveau là parce que
les besoins sont importants il nous faut
créer des effets de levier de lisibilité
et là on a une réelle opportunité de
pouvoir dans le cadre des procédures de
renouvellement mettre en place les
conditions d'avoir une vision plus
partagée que ça soit au niveau national
et régional vous savez qu'au niveau
régional on peut pas parler aujourd'hui
d'un concept de mobilité si on n'a pas
des schémas de mobilité régionaux
départementaux métropolitains qui soient
vraiment complémentarisé et pour ce
faire les concessionnaires devraient
aussi apporter leur propre vision on
voit aujourd'hui des possibilités de
mettre de réserver par exemple des voix
quand on arrive sur les métropoles avec
des aménagements il n'y a pas de volonté
de un véritable volont arisme à l'heure
actuelle des concessionnaires sur ces
sujets là donc il faut directement les
interpeller qu'en pensez-vous
chers collègues pour le groupe RDPI et
pour 3 minutes la parole est à Frédéric
marchand merci monsieur le Président ça
prendra moins de 3 minutes puisque
l'essentiel des questions a déjà été
posée les sujets soulevés non simplement
en remercions à la fois pour la clarté
et la très belle démonstration qui a été
faite le président et le rapporteur sur
un sujet qui est aujourd'hui
effectivement au coeur de nombreuses
interrogations qui s'agissent de l'État
qui s'agit de la représentation
parlementaire mais qu'il s'agisse aussi
et surtout du consommateur j'ai envie de
dire d'autoroute un principe de base
quand même c'est de dire qu'on a quand
même des autoroutes qui sont en
excellente étage je pense que ça tout le
monde est d'accord grâce à des grilles
tarifaires qui incitent à
l'investissement vous l'avez dit
jusqu'en 2035 c'est à la fois l'avantage
de cette grille de fixation de tarif qui
a aussi un défaut majeur vous l'avez dit
c'est que l'État n'a pas conservé la
possibilité d'ajuster les tarifs en
fonction du taux de rendement interne
actionnaire et ce qui nous conduit
aujourd'hui à cette situation qui est
que si j'ai bien lu effectivement le
rapport que avec la rentabilité des
concessions Vinci Eiffage par exemple
soit près du 2/3 du réseau est évalué
12% contre 7,67 initialement prévu lors
de la privatisation alors on voit bien
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit qu'il y a
différentes options qui s'offrent à nous
pour éviter que cette exploitation des
concessions autoroutières deviennent une
véritable rente ces raccourcir la durée
des concessions options qui est
juridiquement la plus solide et
économiquement peut-être la plus
prometteuse introduire une clause de
révision des contrats qui permettra
d'introduire une clause de révision du
tarif des péages par les temps en
fonction du taux de rentabilité j'ai
bien compris que ces options étaient
souhaitables mais est-ce que vous pensez
sincèrement vous avez abordé le sujet
qu'elle soit réalisable avant la fondée
concession dans le cadre du négociation
ou est-ce qu'il faut nécessairement
attendre la fin des concessions afin
d'introduire s'écloser enfin pour
rebondir sur ce que disait à l'instant
mon collègue gilet dans quelle mesure
est-il possible de mieux prendre en
compte les objectifs indispensables
aujourd'hui transition écologique avec
notamment le maillage des bornes de
recharge pour les véhicules également
prendre en compte les voies réservées
notamment tout pour le transport partagé
est-ce que ces critères peuvent selon
vous faire l'objet de négociation ou
doivent-ils être introduits au moment du
renouvellement de la concession merci
collègue pour le groupe CRCE et pour 3
minutes la parole est à Gérard laek
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président de la Mission
monsieur le rapporteur merci et bravo
pour les éclairages que vous nous
apportez moi j'ai eu à traiter aussi
quelques petits contrats de concession
dans une vie antérieure et
je n'ai donc pas de
d'hostilité particulière à l'égard du
mode de concessif j'ai compris au
demeurant qu'il faut quand même être bon
en mathématiques
pas trop mauvais endroit et c'est
nécessaire à mes yeux pour élaborer de
bons contrats et pour assurer de bon
suivi
toutefois moi la question que je me pose
c'est la suivante c'est que dans un
contrat de concession
le concessionnaire est réputé porté
quelques risques
c'est un peu fait pour ça tout de même
risque que d'autres ne peuvent pas
assumer c'est l'avantage du modèle
concessif
et
en acceptant donc d'assumer une part de
risques on peut y trouver avantage en
tout cas le constédant est en droit dans
l'obtenir des avantages alors je ne sais
pas si dans votre mission
si vous avez réussi à identifier les
avantages que procurer le modèle ou qui
était censé procurer le modèle j'ai
entendu que les contrats étaient
élaborés de longue date qu'il n'est
qu'ils n'ont pas été infligés mais
peut-être avez-vous au cours de ces
missions
identifier donc l'avantage que procurer
le modèle
et à l'inverse identifié aussi
l'avantage qui n'était pas au
rendez-vous
donc
il me plairait d'en avoir quelques
éclairages parce que dans la séquence
qui va suivre nous aurons sûrement à
interroger nos interlocuteurs
merci chers collègues pour le groupe Les
Indépendants la parole est à Pierre mais
deviennent
merci monsieur le Président
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur de la commission bancaire
pour ces éclairages
je tiens quand même à rappeler que que
ce rapport cette commission je pourra
fournir un rapport qui est légèrement
redondant quand même puisque notre
excellente de commission en 2015 avait
fait un groupe d'études sur les
concessions autoroutières dont j'étais
vice-président et qui tombait à peu près
sur les mêmes problématiques puisque les
choses on peut bouger c'était l'époque
de Madame de Madame royol alors c'est
vrai qu'au-delà des mathématiques dans
les mathématiques il y a des plus il y a
des moyens je vois il faut le rappeler
comme les périodes de confinement on
était
il y a eu un rapport à charge mais
vraiment à charge de l'Autorité de la
concurrence qui avait d'ailleurs été
dénoncé par plusieurs sénateurs par
plusieurs ministres et ces golem Royal
c'était adjoint les services d'un
cabinet
bien nommé qui s'appelait
microéconomique et qui proposait ce
royal le monde de reprendre les
concessions pour 30 milliards dès le
revendre Bours 50 bon tout ça a été
remis à plat on est tombé sur les à peu
près les mêmes conclusions il fallait 50
milliards pour reprendre les concessions
autoroutières et pour les remettre en
appel d'offre on n'était pas sûr en rh45
milliards de trouver des candidats à des
conditions moins avantageuses mais
au-delà des au-delà des chiffres parce
que c'est compliqué le chiffre en
matière de constitution autoroutière il
faudrait réellement expliquer ce qu'est
un modèle de concession en J on ne parle
il faut quand même parler de
l'investissement qui a été fait au
départ évidemment il y a eu 2002 il y a
eu 2005 mais il y a eu une rachat il y a
une reprise de dette donc un
investissement de départ de 40 milliards
à peu près suit une période de déficit
où on arrive au bout de quelques années
à zéro et une période de bénéfice
et en 2000 en 2015
le cabinet microéconomique savait
calculer avait sorti des chiffres de
rentabilité assez ahurissant puisqu'ils
arrivaient à calculer la rentabilité à
l'instant T dans les périodes de
bénéfice mais on occulter
l'investissement la reprise de la dette
et les années de déficit Dolce c'est
très compliqué de calculer surtout que
ces contrats et sont quand même bien
ficelés vous l'avez dit il y a des
armées de juristes et c'est très
compliqué à demander à démonter et très
cher par rapport aux prorogation
évidemment c'est un problème mais à
chaque progression suivent des
investissements ou des engagements que
les temps n'avaient pas tenu et qu'il
avait payé sous forme de prorogation
c'est c'est aussi le problème moi je
veux quand même voir le positif c'est le
l'état de nos autoroutes aujourd'hui
c'est un vecteur formidable de tourisme
pour notre pays puisqu'on a quand même
les plus belles autoroutes d'Europe et
je me pose des questions au-delà des
reprises première question que je me
pose si on faisait une reprise brutale
c'est la crédibilité de la parole tu
serais quand même gravement
atteinte deuxième problème négocier je
pense que c'est la solution la
négociation mais il est difficile de
négocier quand on fait passer les
concessionnaires pour des voyous dans la
presse c'est ce qui se fait la presse
est déchaîner contre eux en ce moment
c'est de Bonton de se déchaîner comme
les entreprises et qui font des
bénéfices bénéficier record au bénéfice
sur honteux on fait on aura on aura
entendu de tout et ils ont été
complètement stigmatisés dans la presse
donc je sais pas si le moment est
propice à la négociation à mon avis il
vaut mieux attendre une accalmie entamer
des discussions avec eux parler des
futurs concessions peut-être parler de
d'aménagement peut-être sur les tarifs
mais pas de cette façon je crois pas
d'une façon aussi brutale
c'est c'est compliqué il est évident que
c'est quelque chose qui rapporte mais il
y a l'état aussi quand même perso
quelques rondes puisque c'est pas le
dernier et à l'époque Dominique de
Villepin avait qui suivait Jospin en
2002 n'avait pas fait une si mauvaise
affaires que ça perso on avait crié au
scandale puisse t'étais quand même
dégagé une belle manne pour attaquer son
mandat donne-moi les questions que je
pose par rapport à la à l'avenir de ces
concessions si on attend la fin des
concessions ou si on peut les abréger à
quelles conditions et quel candidat
parce que le problème avait été posé en
2015 et à certains conditions on savait
qu'il n'y aurait plus de candidats et
c'était assez particulier quoi
et
si l'État est obligé de reprendre les
autoroutes comme ça a été évoqué aussi
sur certaines pistes étant sûr que les
recettes seraient affectées aux
investissements et à l'entretien des
autoroutes ça c'est autre chose quand on
connaît la situation budgétaire de notre
pays et dans quel état finirait finirait
nos autoroutes parce qu'on fantasme sur
des recettes je suis pas sûr que l'État
s'y reprenait les autoroutes feraient
les mêmes recettes que des
professionnels qui connaissent
parfaitement leur métier
et enfin pour le groupe geste Jacques
ferrique oui
merci merci à vous deux et à vos
collègues pour le travail de cette
commission d'enquête sur le contrôle la
régulation et l'évolution des
concessions je crois qu'effectivement
c'est une mise à plat ça a été dit très
utile et je dirais si ça doit être
ressenti comme une forme de brutalité
par les concessionnaires je dirais une
certaine façon tant mieux parce qu'il y
a de la pression qui est nécessaire pour
rééquilibrer les choses vers l'intérêt
général
alors beaucoup de choses ont été dites
donc j'ai pas je vais essayer d'éviter
de faire trop de redit
la première question c'est sur
effectivement les conditions d'exercice
du travail vous avez eu du fournir et
que les uns et les autres ont fourni que
ça soit la RT l'IGF et puis nous le
Sénat donc sur les conditions pour
suivre réguler essayer de rectifier
l'équilibre économique et financier donc
la surentabilité d'une bonne part des
parce que si j'ai bien compris chacun a
dû un peu inventer sa méthode sa
méthodologie pour mesurer cette
rentabilité actionnaire et quand on voit
les écarts entre les colonnes et les
différents tableaux c'est pas
négligeable donc à votre sens
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
mettre en place
avec ce sacro-saint secret des affaires
pour plus de transparence et de clarté
nécessaire au moins pour les
parlementaires dans cette ordre d'idée
qu'elle renforcement de la RT je sais
que la RT souhaiterait que ces avis que
l'État soit lié par ces les avis de la
RT
donc pour les renégociations les
avenants comment faire en sorte que ça
s'effectue dans des conditions moins
déséquilibrées plus satisfaisantes alors
pour les contrats en cours j'ai entendu
ce qui vient d'être dit pour l'essentiel
c'est c'est pas des bons contrats et et
leurs conditions de suivi sont pas
bonnes donc comment en quelque sorte
arrêter les frais avant les échéances
pas prévu si c'est possible comment
écourter l'affaire tout en garantissant
effectivement une bonne qualité des
infrastructures un réseau à jour par
rapport à ce que prévoyait les contrats
et en bon état alors sur le l'avenir
mais l'avenir c'est dès maintenant c'est
pas simplement en attendant
2031 36 ou je ne sais quoi avec donc
l'expiration qui s'annonce des des
concessions des principales concessions
actuelles on a les péages actuels qui
seront remis en cause de toute façon
d'une certaine façon alors le Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures évoque
à règle européenne constante un risque
de réduction des recettes de 50 à 70%
c'est ce qui dit ce qui signifierait
autant à la charge du contribuable on a
aussi la fin annoncée des moteurs
thermiques qui fait que la TICPE c'est
pas quelque chose de négligeable va
inévitablement s'étioler donc en clair
on a les recettes fiscales liées aux
produits pétroliers qui vont perdre de
leur importance donc la problématique
ça sera donc d'éviter
un paradoxal renforcement d'attractivité
du monde routier donc si on attend
l'issue des contrats si on attend
l'échéance 2035 des fins des thermiques
pour engager la transition de moyens
générée par la route qui irait au rail
on y arrivera pas donc comment faire en
sorte qu'une bonne partie de ces 30 à 35
milliards i Auray même si vous avez pas
la réponse précise vous l'avez dit au
moins vous ne permettez de mieux cerner
la question merci merci je vais donner
la parole à Vincent delaie merci
monsieur le Président je suis je vais
faire vite je suis désolé mais parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
questions et beaucoup de sujets
différents
notre collègue gilet
vérification des travaux d'ici la fin
des cours aux sessions je dirais qu'il y
a quand même une amélioration sensible
sur le suivi des travaux par du fait de
la RT notamment depuis 2015
alors est-ce qu'il faut comme le vient
de dire notre collègue Fernique aller
jusqu'à vers un avis conforme de la RT
quoi qui s'impose au gouvernement
je suis pas sûr mais en tout cas il
faudra au moins que le gouvernement dise
pourquoi il tient pas compte des avis de
la RT quoi c'est toujours pareil il faut
au moins qu'il y ait une justification
qui soit donnée un argumentaire qu'on
puisse qu'on puisse entendre ou pas
entendre d'ailleurs mais critiquer ou
pas mais en tout cas qu'on est quelque
chose parce que là on a l'impression que
de temps en temps le gouvernement ne
tient pas compte des avis de la RT sans
dire pourquoi donc il y a un moment
donné il faut effectivement savoir alors
les investissements effectivement et ça
a été ça a été souligné à plusieurs
reprises il y a beaucoup
d'investissements dans la mobilité
durable
je pense moi que ça peut être imposé au
concessionnaire aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de leur contrat actuel et sans
modifier son projet sans quoi que ce
soit continue des 30-35 milliards il y a
moyen de négocier et notre collègue
médiéviel qui me disait qui disait
est-ce qu'on peut négocier ce qu'on
stigmatiser les sociétés
on les stigmatise pas trop mais moi je
pense que les sociétés d'autoroute non
mais elles ont intérêt elles ont intérêt
à discuter et pour l'instant elle
discute rien dans notre commission notre
commission honnêtement c'était de la
langue de bois l'absence de transparence
totale on les a auditionnés moi je les
ai auditionnés même personnellement dans
mon bureau honnêtement on a du mal on a
du mal à obtenir et je pense que elles
ont tort je leur ai dit d'ailleurs je
leur ai dit elles ont tort elles font un
raisonnement à court terme aujourd'hui
elles sont assis sur un super contrat
qui est en fait c'est des contrats qui
ont été conclus entre l'État et lui-même
donc quand on conclut un contrat avec
soi-même on est on le fait pour la forme
on le fait pas forcément pour le fond et
là elles sont pas du tout adaptées à une
relation normale avec une société privée
alors elle s'assoit dessus elle
considère que si on touche le moins de
la moindre virgule ça y est on touche au
contrat donc il y a un moment donné où
c'est pas possible comme cela et ça fait
des années qui font ça donc en fait leur
stratégie aujourd'hui c'est dire on
encaisse l'argent et on attend 2036 ou
2031 pour ceux qui et je pense pas que
ça soit une certaine façon de faire donc
attendre un peu plus on peut toujours
attendre un petit peu plus mais à quel
moment moi ma stratégie c'est plutôt de
leur mettre la pression et je pense que
la bonne stratégie c'est plutôt de leur
mettre la pression leur montrer que la
puissance publique a aussi alors elle a
une crédibilité elle a des engagements à
tenir mais elle a aussi à des formes
d'intérêt général elle défend pas
l'intérêt privé de tel ou tel elle
défend l'intérêt général et l'intérêt
général c'est de se dire comment on fait
en sorte de garder des bonnes autoroutes
les autoroutes qui se qui se modernisent
qui tiennent compte effectivement de des
plans de mobilité durable peut-être
d'une régionalisation d'une région de de
choses que c'est à ça qu'il faut
réfléchir de quelle façon on peut y
arriver quelle façon on peut le faire
prendre en compte mais tout cela c'est
c'est un équilibre d'ensemble qu'il faut
absolument trouver et pour le trouver
pour le trouver il faut avoir et moi je
leur ai demandé et vous pourrez leur
demander aux sociétés d'autoroute
puisque vous avez les auditionner vous
leur demandez quel est l'équilibre
économique et financier des contrats
demandez-leur et vous me direz si vous
avez une réponse moi je serai je serai
je serai preneur si vous donne réponse
il ne s'engage sans rien du tout il dit
simplement la rentabilité on la verra à
la fin du contrat ben non non si on
attend la fin du contrat c'est terminé
il y a plus rien à discuter donc à un
moment donné aujourd'hui je pense que la
pression elle est sur un peu plus sur
elle tant mieux moi je pense qu'elles
ont intérêt à raisonner plus à long
terme qu'à court terme aujourd'hui le
raisonnement un peu trop à court terme
en disant qu'est-ce on encaisse nos
dividendes on encaisse nos résultats
c'est très bien mais le raisonnement à
long terme est important pour elle parce
que on a des sociétés de qualité ça
serait dommage de s'en priver
je crois que c'est c'est Pierre qui
disait est-ce qu'il y aurait d'autres
candidats bien entendu dans un contrat
de concession il faut pas mettre des
conditions telles que on a plus de
candidats un contrat de concession il
sert à quoi et ça c'était pour répondre
je crois
à notre collègue marchand non ou la haie
c'est là qui demandait les avantages les
avantages c'est effectivement
de prendre un certain nombre de risques
pour le compte de la collectivité
publique mais aussi d'investir à mon
délai la connectivité publique elle peut
pas investir et on peut faire investir
par une société privée en disant ben
elle va s'y retrouver va se faire
rémunérer et c'est ça en fait l'avantage
de la concession et honnêtement l'État a
pas montrer des qualités de
gestionnaires dans beaucoup de domaines
exceptionnels donc à partir à partir de
là on peut se dire pourquoi aller
rajouter une gestion entre guillemets
publics et étatique d'un secteur alors
qu'on a des sociétés qui savent le faire
à condition qu'on les encadre bien et
c'est l'encadrement pour moi qui est
important et l'encadrement le contrat
savoir ce que ce qu'on leur demande et
en fonction de ça voilà et avoir un
partenariat qui soit gagnant-gagnant
parce qu'il s'agit pas d'enfoncer ces
sociétés il s'agit pas des enfoncer ces
sociétés mais il s'agit de les mettre
autour de la table les faire venir
autour de la table parce qu'aujourd'hui
elles viennent pas autour de la table
quand elles viennent autour de la table
c'est avec un avocat et pour dire on va
vous emmener au contentieux donc à un
moment donné c'est c'est pas c'est pas
jouable on l'a vu sur les tarifs les
tarifs effectivement le contrat il
prévoit 70% de l'inflation et c'est une
aberration c'est une libération les
charges des sociétés d'autoroute c'est
30% de leur chiffre d'affaires donc au
minimum ça devrait être au maximum ça
devrait être 30 % de l'inflation parce
que en fait l'inflation elle joue sur
leur charge
elle joue sur leur charge l'inflation et
voilà et aujourd'hui les 4,75% qui ont
été acceptés pour 2023 je l'ai dit ça
fait augmenter les profits des sociétés
d'autoroute de 300 millions par an 300
millions par an donc sur 10 ans ça vous
fait 3 milliards c'est assez simple donc
l'indexation de la tat je veux dire je
dirais que c'est une routine par rapport
à tout cela donc à un moment donné il
faut quand même revenir à du sérieux à
un raisonnement un raisonnement un peu à
long terme par rapport aux sociétés dans
pierre on aura l'occasion d'en
rediscuter si tu veux mais moi j'ai
aucun souci et je tape pas sur les
sociétés privées non non mais Pierre pas
du tout pas du tout je dis simplement
que en l'occurrence en l'occurrence le
rapport normal d'un consédant avec les
concessionnaires n'est pas respecté moi
j'ai eu l'occasion de gérer des
concessions je regrette le considant il
a aussi des pouvoirs il a aussi des
capacités à faire et il doit pas
simplement dire amen aux concessionnaire
voilà alors après
est-ce qu'il faut une nouvelle structure
est-ce qu'il faut un syndicat est-ce
qu'il faut faire évoluer la fuite
moi je ferai plutôt évoluer la fuite
j'aurais plutôt tendance à dire on a on
a une agence ben voilà faisons-la
évoluer en fonction de ce qu'on a envie
elle existe déjà on se dit tiens on va
la pousser et elle peut bénéficier de
contributions qui soient pas volontaire
mais qui soit obligatoire contribution
obligatoire et puis voilà on dit vous
contribuez obligatoirement à une agence
de financement des infrastructures de
transport et ça nous permet de nous y
retrouver
[Musique]
voilà j'ai essayé de
alors peut-être que pour notre collègue
thermique la méthodologie sera
rentabilité je l'ai dit rapidement tout
à l'heure mais
on a défini une méthodologie rentabilité
sur la rentabilité actionnaire elle a
été reprise par l'Inspection générale
des finances elle est validée entre
guillemets par l'Inspection générale des
finances la RT fait un autre type de
calcul et j'aimerais avoir la
transparence de son calcul moi je dis à
la RT je leur ai dit d'ailleurs quand on
est allé sur place parce que moi j'ai
passé une journée à la RT je leur ai dit
moi je comprends rien à votre calcul
j'aimerais avoir les éléments qui me
permettent de le vérifier et une fois
qu'on l'a vérifié on dit comprendra
mieux et on maintenant j'ai bien compris
la différence avec la nôtre moi je
considère que notre méthode est
meilleure et que en tout cas montre
mieux la rentabilité réelle
alors vous avez abordé un point sur la
réduction liée à l'Europe au règlement
européen ça c'est un vrai sujet qu'il
faut approfondir et je pense que votre
commission peut l'approfondir un petit
peu pour savoir ce qui va se passer
parce que il y a eu effectivement un
accord au niveau européen entre suite à
la contentieux entre les Autrichiens et
les Allemands et ils ont fini par dire
on peut plus on peut plus prendre de
péage je mette de péage si on a amorti
toutes les infrastructures quelque chose
comme ça je le dis rapidement et façon
succincte mais en tout cas c'est un
sujet qui mérite d'être un peu creusé
parce que sinon il faut intervenir au
niveau européen pour éviter cela moi je
considère que il faut pas qu'il y ait
plus de péage les autoroutes gratuites
c'est c'est complètement c'est à mon
avis c'est pas une bonne solution il y a
quelques pays qui l'ont qui l'ont fait
mais en fait on fait pas et nous on est
un pays qui est beaucoup traversé on a
beaucoup de véhicules étrangers qui
traversent la France si on se dit bah on
leur fait plus payer les autoroutes ah
bah voilà on en a plus de contribution
d'une bonne partie des des personnes qui
traversent et en plus on favoriserait
l'utilisation des voitures donc c'est
pas c'est pas l'objet aujourd'hui
l'objet aujourd'hui c'est d'arrêter
d'augmenter de façon à considérer les
autoroutes parce que je considère que
les augmentent de façon à considérer et
de récupérer une partie de ces sommes là
pour faire autre chose peut-être avec
une transformation de la fit je m'excuse
on est on est très très rapide mais
comme on doit aller en commission des
finances si on va être sanctionné
financièrement
c'est embêtant merci merci je crois que
je crois que ce débat est intéressant et
je crois que le fait d'avoir engagé
cette ce débat au sein de la commission
d'aménagement du territoire et quelque
chose de fondamental parce que
effectivement comme on le dit il y a des
choses qui nous conviennent bien des
choses qui conviennent moins bien que
comme on peut utiliser les choses et
puis je crois qu'il y a un sujet qui va
falloir quand même que l'on évoque c'est
c'est la décarbonation des autoroutes
c'est quand même un sujet important
voilà donc pour cette audition de
Vincent Delahaye rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête sur les concessions
autoroutières et on enchaîne tout de
suite avec l'audition du président de
Vinci toujours devant les sénateurs et
toujours au sujet de l'avenir de nos
autoroutes
je me réjouis que vous vous intéressiez
à ce sujet de la préparation de
l'échéance des contrats de concession
autoroutières d'abord parce que il se
dit beaucoup de choses fausses sur les
concessions d'autoroute ces derniers
temps et ensuite car la question de la
route est essentielle pour nos
concitoyens aussi bien que pour les
finances publiques au regard des besoins
d'investissement
nécessaire qui ne vont faire que croître
du fait de la nécessité de décarboner
les transports mais aussi du fait des
ressources collectées par la mobilité
routière qui sont appelés à diminuer si
rien n'est fait je voudrais d'abord
rappeler quelques chiffres du côté des
parts modèles la route représentée en
87% des déplacements de personnes en
France cette part est stable depuis 30
ans elle était de 88% en 1990 et
concernant les marchandises la part de
la route en 2021 était de 85% chiffre
constamment croissants depuis que des
statistiques publiques existent la part
de la route était de 58 % en 1994 du
côté des investissements dans les
infrastructures de transport ils sont
globalement constants depuis 1990 ils
étaient de 14 milliards en 90 par an
mais il baisse en part du PIB pour ne
représenter que 0,97% en 2021 là où il
représentait 1,25% en 90 ce qui fait une
baisse relative de plus de 20%. ils ont
été fortement réorientés depuis quelques
années au détriment de la route qui de
65% des investissements en tendance de
long terme et passer à
45%, c'est 20% d'écart ont globalement
été transféré transférés vers les
transports urbains pour 17% qui sont
passés de 11 à 29 % des investissements
et vers le réseau ferré principal dont
la part dans les investissements est
passé de 15 à 19%. du côté des recettes
la route
est fortement contributrice au budget
public le rendement de la TICPE sur les
carburants et de l'ordre de 33 milliards
et le produit des péages autoroutier
était en 2021 d'environ 12,4 milliards
d'euros TTC dont 4,7 milliards
d'impôts et taxe ce qui représente près
de 40% de fiscalité la part hors
fiscalité est intégralement utilisé au
financement des infrastructures
autoroutières et la part fiscale abonde
le budget général mais elle est aussi
pour partie fléchée à hauteur d'un
milliard d'euros pour l'ensemble du
secteur vers les autres infrastructures
de transport par son par l'affectation
au budget de la fift de la taxe
d'aménagement du territoire et de la
redevance de manière
l'autoroute finance donc le ferroviaire
et le record model depuis
95 l'enjeu majeur des politiques de
transport pour les décennies à venir
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président et
la décarbonation des déplacements le
secteur des transports représente
environ un tiers des émissions de
carbone du pays et c'est le seul secteur
dont les émissions n'ont pas baissé
depuis 30 ans
84% de ses émissions proviennent de la
route et près du quart proviennent des
seules autoroutes les VL et les PL
contribuant pour départ sensiblement
égal sur autoroute la stratégie
nationale bas carbone prévoit dans le
scénario qui nous permet d'atteindre les
objectifs de la France en termes de
carbone une part modèle de la route de
79,5% en 2050 pour le transport de
personnes là où on est avec un
objectif intermédiaire de 80 de 4 ans en
2030 et de 85 0
85,3% en 2050 pour le transport de
marchandises avec un objectif
intermédiaire de 86,2 en 2030 et dans le
cadre de la révision en cours de la
stratégie nationale ba carbone le
nouveau scénario rehaus fortement
l'ambition de transfert model en
prévoyant une part modèle de la route de
714% en 2050 pour le transport de
personnes et de 71% en 2050 pour le
transport de marchandises et on le voit
quel que soit les scénarios quel que
soit les scénaris pardon la part de la
route sera et restera prépondérante en
2030 et en 2050 et pour atteindre les
objectifs de décarbonation il faudra à
la fois modérer la demande amplifier le
report modèle mais d'abord et avant tout
c'est le levier le plus puissant
décarboné les mobilités routières ce qui
passe par d'importants investissements
alors nous travailler sur ces questions
de comment décarboner la mobilité
routière et avons construit sur ce
terrain un plan en 5 points le premier
point c'est le développement des
infrastructures et des services de
mobilité par partager pour mieux
utiliser la route qui est une
infrastructure existante et qui mérite
d'être optimisé il s'agit de développer
le covoiturage les pôles d'échanges
multimodos les carexpress sur autoroute
ou les voies réservées il s'agit ensuite
d'accueillir des motorisations
décarbonées dont notamment pour les VL
se dotés d'un réseau de bornes de
recharge ultra rapide suffisant pour
accueillir une flotte ou la pénétration
du véhicule électrique est exponentielle
je rappelle qu'en 2022 14% des véhicules
vendus étaient électriques et c'est ce
qui représente une part super à la part
des véhicules diesel vendus le troisième
axe c'est de faire de l'autoroute un
centre de production d'énergie ren et je
voudrais de ce point de vue dire ma
déception sur la loi d'accélération
récemment promulguée elle fera gagner au
mieux six mois sur les quatre ans et
demi qu'il faut en France pour conduire
construire un parc photovoltaïque là où
il ne faut que deux ans en Allemagne et
alors que il faut 6 mois de travaux pour
déployer des panneaux photovoltaïques
qu'il me semble qu'on aurait gagné à les
déployer rapidement et de façon
volontariste sur l'ensemble des axes de
transport linéaire je pense aux
délaissés ferroviaire ou au délaissé
autoroutier le quatrième axe c'est les
efforts de fluidification du trafic par
l'innovation et la promotion à la fois
des véhicules autonomes est connecté et
puis par le passage en flux libre au
péage et le cinquième point qui est très
important c'est les efforts
d'investissement pour améliorer la
résilience des infrastructures dans les
milieux naturels il s'agit à la fois des
forces sur la biodiversité mais surtout
de la résistance des ouvrages aux
incendies ou aux inondations dont on
voit la multiplication dans la période
récente nous estimons que l'effort
d'investissement sur le réseau
actuellement concédé représenterait
environ 60 milliards c'est un effort
important mais qui ne représente qu'un
tiers de la valeur du réseau concédé
dans les contes de l'État et finalement
il nous faut faire un effort
d'investissement au 21e siècle trois
fois moins important pour décarboner que
celui qu'on fait les générations
précédentes pour construire le réseau
actuel alors il y a bien sûr débat sur
ce montant de 60 milliards et notamment
sur toute la partie d'investissement
qu'il faudrait consentir pour la
décarbonation du transport des poids
lourds notamment parce qu'il y a des
options technologiques et des choix
techniques qui doivent être faits entre
l'hydrogène ou les systèmes de
d'alimentation électrique qui s'agisse
de camions à batterie ou de système
d'induction électrique sur le réseau
autoroutier ou de systèmes de caténaire
et de pantographe et tous ces sujets
sont à la fois au stade expérimental et
au stade de test mais on peut attendre
on peut s'attendre à ce qui est une
accélération sur ce sujet notamment
suite à des réglementations européennes
en cours de débat
l'autre point sur lequel vous m'invitez
à m'exprimer et la question des
ressources et je voudrais simplement
dire que les ressources financières
collectées par les mobilités routières
sont appelés à baisser fortement si rien
n'est fait dans les 15 ans qui viennent
le rendement de la TICPE est d'abord
menacé par la transformation de du parc
et l'évolution de la flotte automobile
et si aujourd'hui les 33 milliards qui
sont prélevés par la TICPE sur le
carburant ne sont pas transférés sur la
mobilité électrique cela veut dire que
la TICPE verra son rendement
baissé de façon très significative les
péages sont également menacés a priori
ils n'ont plus de raison d'être
au lendemain de la fin d'une concession
puisque l'infrastructure est amortie et
les prêts de 5 milliards d'euros la
fiscalité prélevée chaque année
disparaîtront de la même façon si rien
n'est fait certes de nouveau péage
pourrait être instauré dans le cadre de
la directive Eurovignette leurs
composantes principales la redevance
d'infrastructures doit au plus couvrir
les coûts or l'infrastructure a été
amortie à l'occasion de la première
concession et cette redevance serait
alors nettement plus faible et ce
d'autant qu'elle n'a pas vocation à
couvrir de la fiscalité spécifique on ne
peut pas lui adosser la redevance de
manielle ou la tête
si j'ai bien compris la directive
Eurovignette et l'objet premier de cette
directive est d'ailleurs d'éviter que
les pays de transit n'imposent des
péages ou des vignettes trop élevées au
transporteur d'autres pays on parle de
la liberté de circulation en Europe et
le Conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures à lui-même dit que cette
redevance représentait de à trois fois
moins à horizon visible que les péages
actuels la directive permet de mettre en
place une redevance d'infrastructures en
plus de la redevance d'infrastructures
une redevance pour coût externe pour
prendre en compte les externalités
négatives comme les émissions polluantes
les émissions sonores ou la congestion
toutefois d'une part une telle redevance
aurait en droit français une
qualification différente de celle de la
redevance d'infrastructures comme les
péages actuels cette dernière Aurèle
statut de redevance pour service rendu
alors que la redevance pourquoi externe
ne correspond à aucun service il s'agit
donc d'une taxe qui doit être qui doit
respecter l'égalité devant l'impôt il ne
serait donc pas possible de l'appliquer
aux seules infrastructures en
concessions comme le périphérique
toulousain ou le contournement nord
d'Angers au motifs qui sont en
concession sans l'appliquer aussi au
périphériques parisiens ou à l'ensemble
des contournements urbains on voit dès
lors que l'absectes l'acceptabilité
d'une telle taxe ne serait pas
évidente mais aussi que sa collecte ne
serait pas techniquement puisque aucun
équipement ne le permet aujourd'hui et
d'autre part le rendement de la
redevance pour coût externe serait
inférieur au niveau de la fiscalité
spécifique qui pèse actuellement sur le
secteur et il serait décroissant au fur
et à mesure de la diffusion de véhicules
propres alors à la fin après la fin des
concessions historiques le produit des
faits des péages affectés aux
investissements dans les infrastructures
de transport pour être ainsi baissé de 8
milliards d'euros par an voilà ce que je
voulais dire à titre liminaire monsieur
le Président je vous remercie pour votre
attention et je me tiens ainsi que
Blaise rappeur qui est le directeur
général descota à votre disposition si
vous souhaitez que nous précisions ce
propos liminaire
merci monsieur le Président donc on va
donner à parole je vais faire une sorte
de tourniquet pour donner la parole
différemment tout à l'heure donc la
parole est à Nicole Bonnefoy pour le
groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le Président donc mes
chers collègues monsieur le Président
Copé
VINCI Autoroutes et l'un des principaux
concessionnaires privés du réseau
autoroutier français et à ce titre en
partenaire fondamental de la politique
publique des transports que ce soit dans
la décarbonation ou dans le report modal
vous le savez le réseau autoroutier fait
partie intégrante du patrimoine national
et les Français y sont très attachés il
n'y a rien de scandaleux à ce que les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
puissent assurer une certaine
rentabilité cependant lorsqu'il y a une
conjonction d'une sur rentabilité
désormais étayée par un rapport de
l'Inspection générale des finances on
parle tout de même de 55 milliards
d'euros de profits de plus que ne le
prévoyez les contrats initiaux et d'une
augmentation constante des tarifs de
péage il s'agit de s'interroger sur la
plus-value pour l'ensemble des Français
et non seulement pour les actionnaires
aussi comment accueilli vous les récent
déclaration des ministres de l'économie
appelant un raccourcissement des
contrats de concession avant leur
échéance étant donné la surentabilité
des sociétés concessionnaires
d'autoroute en tant que partenaire
êtes-vous prêt à renégocier du point de
vue de l'intérêt général et quels sont
vos propositions en matière de partage
des recettes Clément bonne c'est ainsi
fait l'écho d'une contribution
supplémentaire en direction des sociétés
d'autoroute qui pourraient alimenter les
investissements nécessaires dans le
ferroviaire ou encore l'entretien du
réseau routier non concédé par ailleurs
en tant que concessionnaire vous avez
une responsabilité majeure pour la
décarbonation vous venez de de l'évoquer
sachant que vos résultats d'exploitation
sont excessivement bénéficiaires des
résultats qui interrogent la récente
augmentation des péages de près de 5%
qui dans la période d'inflation que nous
connaissons par et peu ou pas justifiés
quand l'autorité de régulation des
transports reconnaît elle-même que les
recettes augmentent plus vite que les
charges phénomène amplifié par les
baisses d'impôts de production décidé
sous ce quinquennat la question de la
répartition de la charge du pH entre les
usagers me semble déterminantes pour
l'avenir de la route car le signal prix
pourrait permettre à la fois de prendre
en compte une tarification sociale les
véhicules plus ou moins polluants les
problématiques de congestion
l'optimisation de l'usage de
l'infrastructure ou encore les
transports alternatifs à l'auto-solisme
comment VINCI Autoroutes envisage une
digestion dynamique des P des péages
dans sa globalité et plus
particulièrement en direction du trafic
poids lourd qui pourrait régler certains
engorgements comme celui de la rocade
bordelaise et vous savez mon engagement
sur le sujet le 31 janvier dernier vous
avez réalisé un colloque intitulé La
Route grande impensée de la transition
écologique démontrant la nécessité de la
décarbonation des infrastructures
routières nous laissons bien les
transports sont le premier poste
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre vous
l'avez rappelé l'autoroute représente à
peu près 7% des émissions de CO2 pour le
pays 54% provient des véhicules
particuliers 25% des véhicules poids
lourds 21% des véhicules utilitaires
légers le plan de décarbonation de Vinci
Autoroutes s'appuie notamment sur une
étude dirigée par le professeur Pierre
joffronte estimant entre 60 et 70
milliards d'euros les investissements
nécessaires pour faire de l'autoroute
une infrastructure bas carbone à
l'horizon 2030 j'aurais aimé savoir si
cette étude commandée par Vinci qui
engage le réseau concédé sur le long
terme avait fait l'objet d'un contrôle
ou d'une appréciation particulière par
le ministère de la transition écologique
ou d'une agence de l'État tel que
l'ADEME ou encore des collectivités
locales impactés par ce plan leurs
analyses seraient d'autant plus requises
qu'elle permet très d'évaluer les
différents postes d'investissement tout
en les croisant avec d'autres données ou
hypothèse de décarbonation massive comme
la réduction de la vitesse kilométrique
il est selon moi fondamental que les
collectivités nationales et
territoriales concernés est un droit de
regard sur des questions relevant de
leurs compétences en matière de
planification écologique et également en
matière d'aménagement du territoire je
vous remercie pour votre écoute et vos
réponses
je vous remercie Dieu de 57 c'est bien
je vous remercie madame pour cette
question j'ai commencé par
la dernière remarque
vous voulez répondre à celle-ci puis
après on enchaînera répondez à celle-ci
et ben répondez à celle-ci et puis on va
et après on va enchaîner je voudrais
simplement dire sur ce sur ce dernier
point madame que
il y a dans cette salle de nombreux élus
locaux que je connais et avec lesquels
j'ai eu maintes occasion et vous en
faites partie de concertation sur des
projets sur des aménagements sur des
plans d'investissement et je
souscris à votre remarque sur
l'importance de la concertation locale
je rappelle que nous sommes
régis par un ensemble de procédures et
d'enquêtes publiques qui le rend
obligatoire mais que nous avons par
ailleurs le souci de la concertation et
de l'écoute à la fois des territoires et
de leur représentants et donc je voulais
commencer par dire combien je souscris à
cette remarque monsieur le sénateur vous
motorisez à répondre à l'ensemble de la
question alors vous vous m'interrogez et
figurez-vous que sur la question de la
rentabilité des concessions et des
différentes déclarations qui ont été
faites dans la période récente sur sur
ce sujet alors
je voudrais d'abord dire que cette
question
a déjà été abondamment discuté dans cet
enceinte
en 2014 et 2015 et qu'elle a conduit le
législateur
a confié à l'Autorité de régulation des
transports on a transformé la RAF en
arts à faire puis en art en lui confiant
la mission de surveiller année après
année l'évolution du niveau de
rentabilité des concessions d'autoroutes
la RT c'est saisi de cette question avec
beaucoup de sérieux et elle a produit
deux rapports j'imagine que vous en avez
pris connaissance un qui est sorti en
novembre 2020 et un qui est sorti en
janvier 2023 l'un et l'autre de ces
rapports repose sur un travail qui a le
mérite de prendre en compte l'ensemble
du sujet les concessions d'autoroute se
sont des sujets très capitalistiques
très compliquées et très ancien et donc
pour porter un jugement
valable sur la question de la
rentabilité il faut à la fois regarder
les contrats regarder les modèles et
faire des hypothèses la RT a regardé les
contrats regarder les modèles et fait un
ensemble d'hypothèses qu'elle a partagé
avec les sociétés concessionnaires les
hypothèses de quoi on parle quel est le
plan d'investissement quels sont les
hypothèses de trafic quels sont les
hypothèses de financement quelles sont
les hypothèses d'inflation avec ça on
fait tourner un modèle on reprend
le schéma tel qu'il était lors de la
privatisation en 2002 et le ce qui est
réalisé et puis on regarde la
perspective d'ici à la fin de la
concession alors c'est extrêmement
compliqué puisque il est possible de
mesurer la rentabilité d'un
investissement à la fin
pour faire une mesure intermédiaire il
faut faire toutes sortes d'hypothèses
sinon on raconte n'importe quoi et la RT
a fait ce travail et elle a conclu à
deux reprises j'imagine qu'elle a été
auditionnée dans cette maison elle a
conclu à deux reprises que le taux de
rentabilité des concessions d'autoroute
tel qu'il pouvait être évalué à date
c'est à dire tel que on peut le projeter
à la fin de la concession était cohérent
avec ce qui avait été modélisé
lors de lors de la privatisation donc
pour moi le travail sérieux qui a été
fait sur ce sujet a été fait par la RT
avec des modèles dont chacun connaît les
hypothèses maintenant vous m'interrogez
sur les différentes déclarations qui ont
été faites concernant un rapport de
l'Inspection générale des finances alors
ce rapport a été diffusé par la presse
et donc on a pu en prendre connaissance
je voudrais d'abord dire que c'est un
rapport qui a deux ans et demi et que
c'est un rapport qui a été commandé par
l'État dans le cadre d'un contentieux
entre l'État et les sociétés d'autoroute
sur la compensation de la taxe
d'aménagement du territoire enfin de
l'augmentation qu'on a un proprement
appelé l'indexation de la taxe
d'aménagement du territoire sur
l'inflation
cette indexation revenait à un
prélèvement de l'ordre d'un milliard
d'euros à l'époque sur le PNL des
sociétés d'autoroute et elles ont
naturellement
contester cette cette mesure dès lors
que la taxe d'aménagement du territoire
n'était pas compensée dans l'intention
du ministère des Finances alors même que
la loi prévoit que la loi importante
création de la tête et prévoit sa
répercussion dans les tarifs et alors
même que les quatre fois précédentes ou
l'État avait augmenté la taxe
d'aménagement du territoire ça avait été
répercuté dans les péages comme on
atteste les débats parlementaires
d'ailleurs donc un contentieux c'est
noué entre les sociétés concessionnaires
et l'État et le ministère des Finances a
confié à l'Inspection des finances un
rapport qui est un rapport de commande
pour démontrer que la taxe ne devait pas
être compensée
j'en dirai pas plus vous avez ce rapport
et simplement je vais vous dire
deux choses la première c'est que je
vous encourage à aller page 65 de ce
rapport où il est écrit que les écarts
qui ont été calculés par l'Inspection
des finances repose sur un calcul très
hypothétique et doivent être
interprétées avec une grande prudence
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
l'Inspection des finances et comme par
ailleurs contrairement au rapport de la
RT je ne connais pas le modèle qui a été
produit pas plus que je ne connais le
modèle qui a utilisé le sénateur de
l'oeil pour donner des chiffres
comparables je ne sais pas dire où est
le l'erreur ou les difficultés ce que je
sais c'est que l'Autorité de régulation
des Transports a fait un rapport et a
fait un travail sérieux que ce travail a
été diffusé et qu'il est accessible à
chacun et que ce rapport qui est à la
fois transparent puisqu'on connaît le
modèle
et que il a été euh il a été challengé
sur sur ces hypothèses conclut qu'il n'y
a pas de de difficulté voilà ce que ce
que je peux répondre tout en étant
parfaitement lucide sur le fait que le
débat sur la rentabilité des sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroute ne repose
de moins en moins sur des considérations
objectifs et que on est bien souvent
dans des débordements passionnels et
j'en appelle simplement au fait que une
concession c'est un contrat dans lequel
il y a des obligations et des
compensations avec un modèle dans lequel
il y a des hypothèses que ce l'ensemble
de ces éléments sont suivis à la fois
par le ministère des Transports le
Conseil d'État et l'Autorité de
régulation des transports et que si vous
interrogez l'ensemble de ces
institutions elle considère que nous
sommes tout à fait dans le cadre
de ce qui a été prévu dans le dans le
contrat
je sais bien que les montants qui sont
en jeu
surprennent mais au risque de vous
étonner le profit qui est aujourd'hui
fait par la Société des Autoroutes du
Sud de la France est à peu près cohérent
plutôt même un peu inférieur à ce qui
était prévu dans le modèle alors il est
très important parce que une concession
c'est un instrument de financement et
que c'est une société à durée déterminée
durée pendant laquelle on est réputé
rembourser l'investissement initial au
début on perd de l'argent c'est la
fameuse courbe engie au début on perd de
l'argent et à la fin on gagne dans les
profits des dernières années de la
concession de quoi compenser les
investissements initiaux on est
exactement dans les termes du modèle tel
qu'il avait été contractualisé au moment
de la privatisation alors quand on
affiche des chiffres à 90 on se dit où
là c'est ce sont des montants très
significatifs je confirme que ce sont
des montants très significatifs mais les
montants qui ont été investis et que les
profits d'aujourd'hui qu'on pense sont
très significatifs aussi
merci alors on va prendre une série de
ce qu'il y a un orateur par groupe je
vais donner la parole maintenant au
groupe RDP à Michel Dagbert
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président très heureux de vous entendre
aujourd'hui
je suis membre de j'ai été membre de la
commission d'enquête sur les concessions
autoroutières et également membre d'une
commission d'enquête sur la qualité de
nos infrastructures ouvrages à
ce titre je souhaite vous interroger sur
la question de l'entretien de ces
infrastructures les sociétés
concessionnaires sont en effet
contractuellement tenus d'effectuer
l'entretien des voies et des ouvrages
d'art qui leur sont concédés elles ont
ainsi l'obligation de réaliser un
certain volume de travaux les
concessionnaires doivent investir
jusqu'à la fin des contrats afin de
remettre en bon état l'ensemble de
l'infrastructure or en décembre 2022
l'Autorité de régulation des transports
dont on vient d'entendre que vous dites
grand bien sur la qualité du travail des
produits a publié un document très
critique face aux pratiques observées
lors de la passation des marchés de
travaux de fournitures et de services
mais également lors de la passation des
contrats de sous concession la RT rappel
l'importance de disposer de règles
claires sur le calcul de la valeur
estimée d'un marché de travaux et le
choix de la procédure d'appel d'offres
or elle note aussi le taux très
important notamment pour votre groupe
d'attribution de marchés de travaux aux
sociétés liées capitalistiquement à
votre groupe ASF copyrout Escota ont
ainsi passé près de 50% de leur marché
auprès des sociétés du groupe Vinci elle
émet donc des certaines réserves sur le
coup de certaines opérations de travaux
et beaucoup regrettent en effet le
manque de transparence sur les coûts et
les prix pratiqués lors de la
réalisation des travaux d'entretien de
l'infrastructure
pouvez-vous nous fournir quelques
éléments d'appréciation sur ce point et
nous dire où vous en êtes dans la
réflexion sur la mise en oeuvre de
passation plus transparente dans leur
règle d'attribution merci beaucoup
merci chers collègues pour cette
question pour le respect du temps la
parole est à Gérard Elec pour le groupe
C merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président merci merci de vous livrer
à cet exercice dans un contexte
compliqué de tension fait de tension
diverses d'emblée je voudrais vous dire
ici que je n'ai pas d'hostilité
particulière à l'égard du modèle
concessif je l'immense avantage
d'ailleurs d'avoir contribué à enseigner
quelques-uns avec votre groupe
et d'autre part je précise ici que je
viens de Bretagne et donc comme vous
je partage l'attention particulière que
vous les Bretons à l'existence des
routes et de leurs autoroutes d'ailleurs
quand on l'oublie il ne manque pas de
nous rappeler des choses
donc voilà alors certes il s'écrit
beaucoup beaucoup de choses
dans le contexte actuel et nous ne
pouvons qu'être attentifs à ce qui se
dit à ce qui s'écrit
et permettez-moi de vous dire ici que
tout le monde n'a pas pour livre de
chevet le rapport de la RT
ce qui ne simplifie évidemment pas
évidemment ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne
faillit pas objectiver les choses
mais nous sommes confrontés quand même à
une interpellation par la société
sur
un certain nombre de marges dont on
parle beaucoup la presse d'aujourd'hui
encore un peu humoristique en écrit
d'autres
il y a là-dedans que des parts de vérité
et moi je voulais vous demander tout de
même si vous preniez la mesure
de l'émotion que suscite cette situation
dans l'opinion publique
[Musique]